Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Conner's again. Welcome to another episode of Conner's clinic live.
I have a special guest who's been a long time friend of mine, way out of the East Coast.
And I've known Dr. Jeff Dada Tello for what 10 years maybe.
You know, Kevin, I think it's longer than that.
Oh, let's pretend it's not. Okay.
Yes, I think it's posted a 12.13 now who knows time flies.
We are getting older. That's for sure.
Dr. Jeff, I've got to know Dr. Jeff when we were both doing intensive study with
in neurology and functional neurology and Dr. Carrick's work.
We were seeing a lot of people dealing with trying to help their neurology.
Understanding that neurology is the is the basis of a lot of disease.
You can't ignore the metabolic side.
So you've got to kind of pull it all together with functional neurology is really important.
Now I know you're doing, I just looking at your website will give website information
the center for well.com.
You are out in New Hampshire.
I got to stop talking and just kind of turn it over to you.
What what do you like to specialize in?
What is, you know, what have you been led to deal with with helping people?
Well, you know, it's great talk with you Kevin.
You know, I've told so many people about your your cancer therapies and how you've
helped people over the years.
In fact, you actually attracted me.
I went and got a fellowship in integrative cancer therapies years ago because of you.
That's right.
I remember that now.
Yeah, a lot of time ago, I had a bunch of people.
And so my whole thing is to try to optimize people's health by diminishing inflammation
and whether that's through neurology or increasing maximizing,
optimizing their metabolism or a big thing we're kind of famous for now is stem cell therapy,
regenerative therapy.
We've had over 2000 people go through those treatments in our office and you know,
people flying from all over the country were about an hour north of Boston.
You don't have to go overseas to get some really, really neat, regenerative biologics
nowadays for knees and hips and backs and necks and even some systemic issues.
We just can't make claims that we're helping anything specific.
But again, we're at a point now where we really we can talk about this more.
If you're if you're listening to this and you're like, you know, I don't want a knee replacement.
I don't want a hip replacement and you don't know what's out there.
We've had over 350 people cancel knee or hip replacement surgeries that were scheduled.
So that's kind of my cool thing is getting that information out to people and letting people
know that there are options and I have doctors around the country that I help guide through
these processes on what products to inject, what type of regenerative biologics to inject,
not to do it.
And the reality is about eight years ago now, I retired my chiropractic license.
And I realized I was much more entrepreneurial.
So now I have a staff of almost 30.
We have three locations, I have a bunch of nurse practitioners, 10 health coaches.
My wife Kelly is a co-director and really what I do is always my job is to bet out the next.
What's next?
What's what's what's up in coming?
What is working?
And I'm talking with everybody all around the world.
I'm actually working with China right now to try to see what we can do with them.
And it's just a fun, fun place to be, to be on that cutting edge.
Well, I know in our area, I mean, there is like multi-million dollar orthopedic facilities popping up everywhere.
And the argument is, well, you know, people are living longer.
They're trying to stay healthy.
They're out exercising.
What do they do when you're 60 years old and you decide to take up jogging?
You hurt yourself.
What do they do?
They go to the orthopedic surgeon.
They get injections of steroids and then push you towards surgery.
It's not like if you have to have that done.
It's like, when do you have to have that done?
That's kind of the expectation in our culture today.
What would you do if someone was like, okay, I really damaged my knee.
They're saying it's bone on bone or they're saying it's the ligament that I need surgery.
And the meniscus is damaged.
What would you do?
How would you take that patient from that point?
Yeah, so I should start off by saying almost every one of our people have been told
it's bone on bone.
And when they hear bone on bone, they think they're done, right?
They think of, I was compared to the, the, the tin man and the Wizard of Oz, right?
Before Dorothy squeaked the oil on his joints, right?
And they have this fusion and nothing is going to get in between it because that cartilage
is gone and they just need to rip it out and put a new one in.
That's very rare.
If you can bend your knee and move and you still have mobility in the joint,
we can regenerate tissue.
Are we going to make you 18 again?
No, but the average person gets, if we, we've cut pretty much to a point where 90%
of our people that we accept is patients get 60 to 80% better with one injection
of purified amniotic fluid.
So we can talk more about that.
But really what we do is an ideal person is someone that's gone to the doctor
and in your doctor, you know, they want to help you, right?
They're in the profession of helping people.
They are just unfortunately managed by insurance companies and pharmaceutical companies
and they're just a pawn in the overall scheme of things in the United States.
If you have an acute injury and again, I'm talking to you, I'm talking, I'm
preaching to the choir, if you have a cardiac event, right?
If you have a stroke, if you have a heart attack, if you break a bone, nothing's better.
But for that C word, that chronic word, right?
Not good, because they're going to give you a drug in the case of a joint or a damaged
tissue that's been damaged for over six, 10, 12 months, they're going to try to decrease
that information with a corticosteroid and pray that it works.
And sometimes it does.
But when they're talking to you about a second injection, a light bulb should go off.
Okay, because they used to do four corticosteroids injections.
Now they do two or three and they will start talking about replacement and it's
kind of just like the pattern and they, you know, you're a consumer.
You listen to the guy on the white coat.
Unfortunately, all right, what we do is it covered by insurance.
It can be $4,000 a knee and this is what people shut off this podcast, right?
Sometimes, but the reality is this, if you get a knee replacement, it's usually around
$40 to $50,000.
Many, many people feel like they've been told that they have full coverage.
Their secondary is going to pick it up.
I don't know about you, but we see all the time these horror stories where the coverage
really was only 80%.
It was 90% and ironically, they still end up, they go through this procedure where in the
case for knee, there's about a 20% to even some people say 25% failure rate.
And they still have to pay out of their pocket four to five grand.
So with us, it's something that as long as you have a doctor, a nurse practitioner,
or a, some with primary care status who's looking at the joint, right?
And this is a problem with this regenerative stem cell world.
There's a lot of poor players.
We want to make sure that we use a very strict inclusion and exclusion criteria.
And what that means is this, we don't want to take on everybody as a patient.
If you come into our office and you're, you have all these comorbidities, right?
And you know what those are Kevin, right?
The whole world learned what comorbidities are during COVID because people with multiple
COVID morbidities died from COVID because they weren't healthy, right?
So the same thing with us, if you're type two diabetic, if you're hemoglobin A1C is sitting
around 9, 10, 8, 9, 10, if you're on three, four blood pressure meds, if you're on statins,
if you have a laundry list of medications, we can't just put a regenerative biologic in you
and expect you to get better, right?
So we want to make sure we have a good patient.
You can be on a few meds as long as you're overall healthy.
If we can inject a joint with ultrasound guidance, this is important.
We use ultrasound to look and see what that damage tissue looks like.
And part of my job is getting our nurse practitioners trained.
We send them all over the country to get trained in the right techniques.
They make sure that they get a good patient sitting in front of them, a good candidate.
And then we put this product in you that I can talk a little bit more as far as where it comes from.
And people get better.
And so do you want to hear a little bit about where it comes from and how that works?
I do, but first I want, I think everybody's publicity into this is like, well, do I have to fly out there
and stay there for six weeks?
I mean, what would be the reality of what do I have to do to get this done?
You know, what are the steps?
Yeah, so if you're interested in, again, I'm not trying to sell my practice, but people always ask, like, what do I do?
If I want to see you, you sound like you know what you're talking about.
The first thing is go to the website and really get a feel, you know, if you feel comfortable, what we do.
Because, you know, we're really solid.
We are embedded in our community in our north of Boston, New Hampshire.
But to answer your question, if what they would do is typically they would contact the office.
We would do a zoom with someone from farther away, where Crystal or what Tandy, our nurse practices would talk to you.
Get a good feel if we're on the same page.
And if we are on the same page, what will the next step would be to say, okay, do you want to come out and get this done?
To be clear, based on what you've told me, if everything stays in these guidelines, then you can probably get this done.
And you'll stay for 24 hours afterwards.
And the procedure is simply come in just like it's an inoffice procedure.
You know, you're not getting scrubbed in procedure with an anesthesiologist in a hospital.
Everything is done very clean.
It's a very safe procedure out of the 2000 patients we've had.
We've had zero issues.
Some people might feel a little bit yucky afterwards, but what we're putting in you is what nature uses to heal.
And it's it's injected.
You go home, you go to your hotel and then you fly the next day.
You fly out and the healing typically, the average person is going to feel about in the first six weeks.
They're going to notice about a 50% improvement.
We have people that walk out, feel like a million bucks.
All right.
So is there a second injection that needs to be done or do you decide that?
Does that does that patient decide that while that really helped a lot?
But could I do a second one and six months to, you know, give it a boost?
Should I do it once a year?
I mean, what's the follow up?
Yeah, our recommendation typically is if you get to a certain level, right?
And something will get 100% better, they're done.
If you get 50, 60, 70, 80% better, what we have now is people that will come back and get a second one.
And it's almost like painting another coat of paint on the wall, right?
Let's see, I have a red room and you put white on it.
It looks a little pink, but it's better.
Now we can put another white coat on it and it looks really good.
That might happen down the road.
We've had, I would say 10 to 15% of people come back.
But if it's, you know, it's, it's really up to you.
And a lot of times what people will do is they'll test out one joint because
who has just, you know, when you're 50, 60, 70, who has just one joint that's problematic, right?
If you're athletic or if you do a lot of sports, you're probably going to have shoulder issues
and you're probably going to have knee issues and, and your low back hurts.
And so a lot of times people will put a toe in the water, get something done, get great results,
and then come back and get another body part done later.
Okay.
And people need to not be scared of that because I mean, good to say if you go get your knee replaced,
you're looking at weeks of physical therapy, rejects with your orthopedic surgeon.
I just, I mean, the list goes out and on.
You think you're out of the woods after the surgery and that's a major surgery that you have to recover from.
I do want to touch before you get into the, what's in the injection.
I think there'll be people that might be interested in that, but I do want to touch on because,
you know, we see people that have cancer, you know, so there's a difference between,
you know, systemic stem cell therapy and localized injected stem cell therapy.
Could you talk a little bit about that difference because I know a lot of people with cancer are like afraid of,
if I do, you know, you hear about stem cell therapy with cancer, you can't really talk about that
and do that in the United States, but there are places that are doing that.
But there's, you know, pros and cons to that.
Can it stimulate, circulated tumor cell, you know, growth and such.
So talk about the injectable, so a person has got cancer, but they also have bone on bone on their hip.
You know, what is the pros and cons of doing injectable stem cell?
Yeah, that's was great about this.
I want to be clear that these are not stem cells, what we use.
This is an ace cell of the product.
This is next generation.
It's what the stem cell secretes.
So yeah, sure, in the United States, you're not going to be able to probably get stem cells.
You could go to foreign countries and then could, in the foreign country,
if you have cancer, could it be made worse?
We don't know.
There's theories that it could.
There's not a lot of research on that right now.
But to be clear, if you have a cancer and you have a joint problem, what we do,
and this is where this gets into the nitty gritty of the difference between now and maybe years ago,
is that we use a product that's called purified amniotic fluid.
So anyone that's given birth knows that that baby is protected by this fluid,
not only from if the mom tripped and fell, right, mechanical protection,
but it's also protected from the mom's diseases, right?
So this fluid is what nature has got us,
nature's got to this point over 80,000 generations, 2 million years.
We've adapted to all these things coming at us because this amniotic fluid is filled up
with what are called extracellular vesicles, right?
Exosomes, micro vesicles, eptoptic cell bodies, all these things,
these little things that are out to create healing, right?
So what we do is we have a way of putting, we've got a move,
there's a scientist that I've worked with, a bend in the lab,
I've seen what he does.
The FDA has been into this lab many times.
He's passed with flying colors.
It's, and you want to make sure you know the lab and the scientist.
So I work with a Dr. Ian White, Neobiosis is a company in Florida.
They, what they do is they work with a cord bank and the mom,
if she's scheduled for a C section birth in certain hospitals,
she'll raise her hands, fill out the paperwork and say,
I want to donate my amniotic fluid, which is, right?
So nobody, no babies are harmed.
And at birth, that amniotic fluid's taken out enough for 200 needs.
To be honest with you, there's a ton of this product out there.
It's taken out and it's a, it's tested by a third party.
Under FDA guidelines, the same way that our blood is tested for disease.
And what it is is in this, the product we use is 250 billion
micro vesicles, okay?
So a micro vesicle, think of it as a little bubble.
And in that little bubble are all these cool things that help you heal.
Messenger RNA and micro RNA are really what does the work.
So a messenger RNA is going to upregulate and downregulate genes.
And short, it's going to tell your immune system, hey, let's get stronger.
And then micro vesicles are, so the micro RNA is going to create proteins,
the building blocks of everything to make structure happen.
So if you have damage, let's say a knee going back full cycle here to you,
not you, but someone like, they might have arthritis in their knee.
Arthritis is inflammation.
It's your body's way of saying, hey, fix me buddy, fix me.
The problem is you don't have enough stem cells to create these micro vesicles
on your own. You just, you don't.
And what you do have is old.
And it just doesn't work.
So what we do is we put 250 billion of these little bubbles in
and they turn on your immune system.
There's new proteins and we can create new tissue so that we can smooth out that joint
and get better mobility, better function without drugs and without surgery.
That's why as we age, we don't heal as fast.
We don't heal as well.
And you're just basically giving the body that extra boost to be able to do what it could do.
Yeah. I mean, that's why cancer hits most, not most, but a lot of people later in life,
not all cancers, but because their immune system is weaker.
Everything's slower and doesn't happen, nothing happens as quickly.
And cancer is able to take over where everyone has cancers in them.
But if you have a strong immune system, it's going to be knocking them down constantly
and you won't even get symptoms or it won't even be a problem.
But as cells get close, they go through senescence, right?
The telomeres on the end of your chromosome shot just shrink.
It's called aging and we can reverse that in many ways to a certain extent to give people,
you know, a healthier, longer, better longevity.
Well, I know a lot of our listeners are going to want to hear this and want to get a hold of you.
We'll have your website information up on this podcast, but share a little bit more about your clinic
and where people could reach you and how they could have a consult.
Let's say they live in California, they don't, they can at least have a telephone consult with you or what are your step up?
Sure, sure.
So it's CenterForWell.com.
I'm sure it'll be in the show notes, CenterFOR well.com
and it's Center for Wellbeing with three locations.
All they have to do is call and it's a pretty easy process to get in.
But the whole thing is talking on the phone beforehand to get an idea of what's going on.
If you go to the website, you really, there's a webinar on there where I talked about this whole thing a little bit more detail.
It's about 22 minutes long, but I think the best thing is just to go to the website and then go from there.
Well, I know that this is a huge issue and people get scared and they just go down the orthopedic route and I can speak
from people that I, you know, not just patients but family members.
I know that what did the replacement surgery or hip replacement surgery and greatly regretted it.
And if there's anything that you could do to help prevent that, I would highly recommend it.
And you talk about, okay, well, people get scared away with a $4,000 bill.
Good to say, I mean, you spend $4,000 on junk food.
It's like, this is, this is something that is worth investing in if this is your ability to stay mobile, to stay younger.
Yeah, people spend it on lattes, which, which again leads me to my next thing.
If you go to a website, you're going to see a metabolic reset weight loss program, okay?
And that's a large component to what we do.
We get weight off people very, very quickly and quite frequently when the weight comes off of them,
the average person loses 20 to 40 pounds in three months.
When the weight comes off, the inflammation dives down and they feel better in their joints.
So a lot of times we'll have people and we can do this from a distance.
We use functional medicine or we have a program just with our health coaches where the whole goal is to stabilize insulin and to
have the body become getting kind of a fat burning mode and it's with real food.
It's not prepackaged meals. We teach people how to eat, how to shop.
That we try to work on people's belief systems.
If they have physical, chemical and emotional stress, then they're not going to be able to lose weight, right?
So you know this. If they're not sleeping well, their cortisol is going to be spiked.
We have to teach him how to sleep. Maybe it's not the, not for Sunday.
They're reading three times a week. Maybe their sleep just is horrible.
And you know, maybe, maybe their, their emotional stress is through the roof.
Maybe their, their kid needs to be booted out of their house, right?
Or they're, they eat a new job, but they need to get a divorce.
And that's creating stress that is causing their body to be in a fight or flight response.
And they're inflamed and their joints hurt because they're inflamed.
So we've got to look at the full picture.
So it's a functional metabolic reset weight loss program and regenerative
biologics combined.
There's not a lot of better things for getting people healthy.
Well, we're going to have you on again, if you're willing to talk just about that whole weight loss program, because that is obviously an issue in our society as well.
Yeah, not as much to my listeners with cancer issues.
Maybe that's not what their main concern is, but I do know we have, you know, I have cancer patients, members that talk to me on a regular basis about
joint issues and D issues and hip issues and not wanting to do the surgery while they're in the middle of cancer treatment.
But this is something you can do.
So this is going to be of great interest to a lot of people.
Dr. Jeff, I just thank you for being the full, the full gamut for this, this type of condition, not just, you know, somebody who's just
injecting people with something to make money and that was and can be an issue with different practitioners around the country.
So you have to really, you know, I know that's why we always clicked as friends because you were passionate about healthy people.
And I always respected that about you.
So we want to have you on again.
Great.
So much for me and our guests today, and I know people will love this information and be contacted you to move forward.
Thank you.
No, I appreciate the opportunity.
We'll talk soon. It's always good talking to you.
You're like top of the pile when it comes to people who understand what's going on.
So I appreciate that.
Well, thank you so much.
All right. We'll talk again soon.
Thanks again.